talked about the new normal as it's
getting created in the valley
and that of course includes schools
clark county school district trying to
achieve
its new normal and it's asking for
parental input
sasha lofta spoke to the superintendent
about his efforts
to involve our community she joins us
live from ccsd headquarters
with the latest
brian dr jara says he really just wants
everyone to
use their voice here i also spoke with a
ccsd
parent tonight and he says while he's
grateful for all the work that's being
done here
he really needs to know his daughter is
safe before he sends her back to class
when the protection for a kid you know
frank lamelli is considering the best
options to keep his daughter
safe you see that she's going to end up
going to
high school or waiting to test vaccine
or
trust you know the superintendent and
the governor that
mckee is going to be safe as campuses
across the valley look forward to
fall the clark county school district
wants parents
like lomeli to weigh in when it comes to
covid19
safety we just want to go out and reach
out to the entire community
superintendent dr jesus jorah and his
team released
this online survey thursday this was an
effort to get a broader
an entire community input not only our
parents our students
you know and folks that are out and
throughout the community to go ahead and
fill it out
it asks what families find most
important offering options like limiting
classroom seating
blended learning and enhanced cleaning
procedures
obviously for us to be able to guide our
decision making and though he still has
concerns over keeping his kids healthy
lamelli says he trusts school and state
leaders
to have a good
plan you know for for us parents to be
calm you know and for kids to be safe
to make the right decision for all of
our valley students
they have a lot of work to do
now the entire ccsd survey takes about
10 minutes it's online
and it is anonymous if you'd like to
take that survey or learn more about it
we have that on our website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live
sasha loftis
8 news now